l'annonce est arrivée au milieu de la
nuit aux États-Unis et fait depuis la
une des journaux télévisées américains
c'est une visite surprise le président
zenzky est en chemin pour Washington une
visite historique organisée pour des
raisons de sécurité dans le plus grand
secret même si hier le président
ukrainien y a fait allusion en
déplacement à barmut dans l'est de
l'Ukraine une ville assiégée par les
forces russes un soldat lui remet un
drapeau volodi mirzelinski en profite
pour faire passer un message nous
passerons ce drapeau de nos hommes au
Congrès américain et au président des
États-Unis nous sommes reconnaissants de
leur soutien mais ce n'est pas assez
c'est la première fois depuis le début
de la guerre que le président
ukrainien sort de son pays signe de
l'importance à ses yeux de cette visite
il sera reçu en fin d'après-midi à la
Maison Blanche par le président Joe
Biden la dernière rencontre en chair et
en os entre les deux hommes remonte à
septembre 20 Washington volodi
mirzelinski s'exprimera ensuite devant
le Congrès américain auquel il s'était
adressé à distance en mars dernier
recevant à l'occasion innovation nourrie
moment crucial alors que les
parlementaires américains s'apprêtent à
voter une nouvelle aide massive à
l'Ukraine de près de 43 milliards
d'euros une aide qui comprend la
livraison d'un système de missiles
solaires patriotes un bijou
technologique réclamé de longue date par
l'Ukraine
la Russie adorait déjà fait savoir que
toute nouvelle livraison d'armes à
l'Ukraine ne ferait qu'aggraver le
conflit